if you look at the way society is now
what do you think the average 24 year
old oh no they're they're they're out
living their best life um
and i think i think maybe it was my
circumstances of being in a long-term
relationship
having a lot of miscarriages and knowing
that i wanted kids
so it set me up for like that was going
to be my priority so i was going to ask
if that made you like grow up fast
because of that yeah i think
i when i first got pregnant i was you
know i've been with him
a while but
it wasn't something that i was planning
but then when i lost the baby it i was
like no i this is what i want like i and
it was you know it became like
the
at the forefront of my mind that i know
i wanted to have and also i didn't ever
have anyone around me that had a happy
relationship i never had i think i had
one friend um whose parents are still
together from secondary school that had
that kind of good setup but i never
witnessed that but i knew
that that is what i wanted because i'd
seen so many bad relationships and so
much unhappiness that it kind of made me
go in the opposite direction
no i i grew up in a i grew up in a
single pet from when i was four and um
my dad's been about
you know he's in my life he's been in
and out of my life but he's been in my
life mostly so i had him around which i
think it can be very different if you
haven't got a father figure or a mother
figure but um
but yeah but i knew what i wanted was
the opposite of what i had as a child
and what
qualities did you look for in your
husband that most of your friends like
did not
look for in their partners obviously
there was attraction first thing because
i think that is important
and i met him on
plenty of fish
oh seriously
that is not a place to
[Laughter]
[Music]
and it was very different i think to now
oh my god but it was very different i
think to how it is now like i don't envy
people who are going i've got friends
who are still single in their 30s and
the thought of it makes me feel kind of
sick like that just it's very much i
think a sex yes now um but it wasn't so
much then i mean obviously it was but it
wasn't as bad um but i looked for so
first of all attraction that was you
know drew me he was actually the only
guy i ever contacted because my friend
showed me there was this new like nearby
person like that you could see and then
he came up and i just saw his face and i
was like he's got a nice smile i'm
attracted to him and then
but what i was looking for was someone
who was kind had the same values as me
had the same goals um was you know had
something they wanted to do with their
life that was on the same kind of
similar as what i wanted to do
and
very family orientated he's one of nine
he's um ghanaian he comes from a very
good
african brother yeah
[Laughter]
do you know why i'm actually a better
cook than him
i can make the jollof better than him
but but no no
he can cook he can cook um but um
but yeah i i wanted someone who came
like had a good family
kind of
set up wanted
wanted the same things as me see in the
context of the question though what this
sounds like to me is that
if we're looking at it from a man and
woman's perspective women tend to be the
problem then because i think
the majority of men are looking for what
your husband currently gives you but
then a lot of women are ignoring that
man because we did say okay what's a
woman that's your age or 24 at the time
doing the girl said festivals in hot
girl summer
what part of that is the man's problem
because that sounds to me like it's the
woman's problem i agreed
well just like her i was married young i
oh you've been married yeah i had a
child i was pregnant at 18
my first love stayed with him married
him
tried to make it well because i had this
ideal of what i believed a relationship
was and when that didn't work out for me
i realized like you said at the
beginning of the this chat that
i wasn't taught how to vet
so although i embodied the
characteristics of okay i want to be a
wife i want to be a mother family is
important i've left school to do this
like i want this to work i realized i
don't know how to do this what kind of
guy was the guy
to be honest he he was a nice guy
but i realized at the time i was
vulnerable so the relationship was
started off based on a lie
so everything i thought i knew about him
was not true
but i loved him through that anyway so
he was acting like he's a legit guy but
really he was drilling and trapping no
he wasn't doing that he was committed to
me
but
doesn't mean he wasn't committed that
means he's doing that no he wasn't a
road man what what for his circumstances
he
was he he didn't he told me the wrong
name
he lied about his age and i found out he
did not have um legal status to be in
the uk
okay that attracted you to this guy he
was kind
he was caring he was considerate he was
patient
how long were you together before you
found this stuff out i was with him for
like a year before i found out all of
this how did he find it out he confessed
when i was eight months pregnant
okay i wanted to say something but he
was like he wasn't a bad guy he wasn't a
terrible person i want to say something
i don't i don't agree with the concept
that
you have to throw the blame to the to
the women only yeah i think it's
irresponsible for a man
to just go about getting women pregnant
or sleeping around no i i don't want to
go with this sleeping around my feet is
very irresponsible it leads to that
though mm-hmm no no no it's just women
you might be careful but women women are
women are in control of sex though men
are in control of relationships so like
like it's like
yeah nick cannon's irresponsible but
who's more irresponsible the men are the
women opening their legs when he's got
seven baby mamas
yes exactly i agree and so shouldn't we
also point hands at someone who knows
that he has seven baby mamas and makes
it eight of course yeah but but the
thing is who's in but who's who's in
control of getting pregnant we're in
control of being on birth control we're
in control if you want to be in an iud
you can you can you can get an abortion
too so that's indeed the guys but these
are all damaging things to our bodies
and trauma yes you know women that are
on birth control are 40 more likely to
commit suicide
[Laughter]
there are side effects but the point is
you only ovulate a couple days in a
month who knows when you're ovulating we
do yeah and so yeah so we're a hundred
percent in control of birth yes we are
and so that's why it's our
responsibility when we get pregnant
because we're a hundred like no one has
more power and reproduction than us
i i agree with that i agree that a woman
has more power
i'm saying that isn't the man having any
responsibility in ejaculating to a woman
to strap her i mean yeah he doesn't have
any responsibility
this is what i'm saying at the end of
the day think of it if you was a woman
yeah and you know that if you get
pregnant about the the risk of the man
running away is there regardless
right yeah and then at the end of the
day if you get pregnant that's you for
nine months that's your body you mean
eighteen years about now yeah no no i'm
saying i'm just saying initially when
you're pregnant you're basically out of
action you're vulnerable you don't say
you're continually vulnerable
let me land though
at the end of the day if you know you're
at risk of all those things wouldn't you
take more precautions to protect
yourself yes
random guy that you sleep with i agree
but no one's saying that oh it's not a
man like as a man you're an adult you
know if you if you're busting nuts in in
girls you need to understand that she
might get pregnant no one's saying that
but that has no accountability or is
what we're saying is that in terms of
you actually getting pregnant as a woman
you're you have more power and authority
okay so i i have a question as many of
you know i was just banned on tick-tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible